this is richie bracamontes speaking for
reviewer alessandro barbosa naughty dog
is one of the most recognizable names on
playstation hardware and the roaring
success of its uncharted franchise
across two generations of consoles plays
a large part in that legacy makes sense
then that the studio's first full
release for the playstation 5 celebrates
that storied history bringing two of the
series best entries to new hardware with
a suite of improvements that make
experiencing the treasure hunting
adventures a pleasure again although
some of the underlying design choices
are showing some age the legacy of
thieves collection is the best way to
play uncharted 4 a thief's end and
uncharted lost legacy
they come take cover
bullseye
across both games the most significant
changes are clear to see in the game's
three modes of play fidelity mode
targets a native 4k presentation with
the frame rate aiming for a locked 30
frames per second the new performance
mode which is likely the best way to
play reduces the resolution to 1440p but
doubles the frame rate to 60 frames per
second which it easily maintains for
much of the responsive gameplay a third
mode performance plus cuts the
resolution even more with a native 1080p
presentation and a frame rate that aims
for 120 frames per second you'll need a
display that supports that in the first
place and even then it's a tough
concession to make visually for added
fluidity that's not really required for
the narrative focus adventures that this
collection contains what the additional
horsepower of the ps5 offers then is
choice which wasn't present with the
original releases for both the ps4 and
the ps4 pro both uncharted 4 and lost
legacy have been playable on ps5 through
backwards compatibility but have been
frustratingly locked to the same 30
frames per second cap as the ps4
versions in both respective campaigns
the higher frame rates for both were
reserved for their respective
multiplayer modes which aren't included
in this legacy of thieves collection
anyway the improved performance
dramatically enhances both games
especially when balancing the resolution
and overall frame rate the performance
mode lets its distinctly detailed levels
and picturesque backdrops maintain their
eye-catching allure while the
moment-to-moment action feels better
than ever with its high frame rate
uncharted's occasionally sluggish
shooting feels snappy and responsive and
i found myself able to quickly clear
enemy encounters with more confidence
than i did playing the originals how
much this influences your decision for a
replay is subjective but it's a
fantastic way to experience both games
for the first time it's in replaying
uncharted 4 specifically where the
game's slow but measured opening hours
become a bit difficult to overlook
especially when the narrative surprises
that they build towards are dulled for
players who've seen them already
admiring the game's ability to make use
of the improved hardware only goes so
far when you're trundling atop the roofs
as young nathan drake or going through
the motions of a prison escape that's
meant to set up a core conflict of the
sequel it's a story that benefits so
heavily from initial surprises that
revisiting them doesn't offer the same
impact which you need to keep in mind
when considering that this upgrade isn't
free this won't apply if you're coming
to uncharted 4 for the first time and
it's time since release hasn't made its
subtle shift in overall tone and
climactic finality to drake's story any
less impactful unlike other publishers
sony has committed to the increased 70
retail price for its ps5 games and thus
the legacy of thieves requires either a
full purchase or a 10 upgrade fee if you
own either uncharted 4 or lost legacy on
ps4 it can be a frustrating fee to pay
especially when you consider that the
last of us 2 naughty dog's latest game
received a free patch to unlock the
game's frame rate on ps5 last year
thankfully you only need to own one to
get access to the entire collection
which might come in handy if you jumped
into the final chapter in nathan drake's
story but missed out on the stellar side
story starring chloe fraser and
uncharted 4's antagonist nadine ross
given that numerous other games have
seen similar upgrades without the same
charge you might find it difficult to be
comfortable with the surcharge but at
the very least you're getting both games
for just a single purchase if you did
miss out on the lost legacy the first
time or are returning to it again it
doesn't suffer nearly as much from age
as uncharted 4 does taking all new
additions from uncharted 4 the small
open hub areas and the inclusion of a
grappling hook lost legacy tightens up
the pacing and reduces the overall
length both of which make its story
punchier and its flows more exhilarating
it's still a sizable adventure clocking
in at around 10 hours but the pace at
which set pieces arrive and resolve
never mind the much brisker opening make
it a more suitable way to experience
these new technical enhancements if
you're just looking for a sample as
opposed to a time-consuming replay of
uncharted 4.
outside of the additional visual flair
the legacy of thieves collection also
adds support for both the ps5 dual
synths and 3d audio the enhancements on
the dual sense should be unsurprising
with the adaptive triggers offering some
resistance for weapons and the
controller's vibration adding a lot more
granularity than the dualshock 4. while
not novel anymore the work naughty dog
has done with these features still feels
premium with some of the best adaptive
trigger tuning i've experienced yet on
the console the most impressive
enhancement however is the one that 3d
audio provides there's just so much more
you can pinpoint in uncharted's levels
with this setting on down to the gentle
ping that drake's grappling hook makes
against his belt when he's moving or
climbing
it's again one of the best examples of
this technology making it stand out more
than most titles that support it there's
no question then that you're getting a
vastly superior way to play both of the
playstation 4's uncharted entries
afforded by the more powerful hardware
of the new generation of consoles the
upgrades are in line with what many
other games from other publishers are
putting out for free for players but the
upgrade structure here does allow you to
grab both games for a small fee even if
you own only one that softens the blow
somewhat but it's a factor to consider
if you've already experienced both games
with uncharted 4 faring worse with its
extremely slow opening when played
through again
these are still both exceptional games
made better by more powerful hardware
making it an easy recommendation if
you've missed them over the years
hey nate
yeah
just uh
ah just bring me back something shiny
will you
that's the plan
well
let's go pay our respects to captain
avery huh